I warmly welcome you to
today's lecture on karl marx marx
was yes and i think
we can rightly use this superlative
undoubtedly one of the most important
philosophers of the occident marx made the
really immodest attempt
to recognize the law of motion of the entire history of mankind
he has it  he was also a
historian, he looked into the past,
studied history and
tried to recognize the regularity of the
successive epochs
and not only that,
as we know, he also derived forecasts for the further
future and one of
these forecasts you all know  is
the prognosis of the imminent demise of
capitalism the failure of
capitalism we will deal with this prognosis
today and of
course marx not only wanted to
recognize the connections between human history or history, so to speak, it was also about changing the world
and so he has  together with
feuerbach the following claim or thesis was
put forward i quote
the philosophers have just interpreted the world
differently
it depends on changing it
it depends on changing it you
see here it is already directed
against classical philosophy
for 2000 years people have only ever tried
to understand the world and the whole thing and no,
the philosopher has to change the world
and one can say that karl marx has certainly
contributed to the fact that the world
has changed about 100 years after his
death,
about a third of the entire
human population the marquis counts on
communism  lived in a
society model that
referred to marx, to marxism, and
you have to think about it, marxism
took hold in countries as different
as in the soviet union, i.e. in
russia like tina, but also in cuba,
in nicaragua, in mozambique,
so you see  the communist
revolution was actually a
worldwide phenomenon
and i think not to forget
the german democratic republic, of course,
the cities were named after him
karl marx stadt, which also referred directly
to this philosophy and to
marxism and i think that
marx had these tremendous  had an impact and
you can also say never before so never
before never since then has a
philosopher had such an impact the reason
for that is certainly that he
had brilliantly simple and clear thought leadership
and now let's see why
he was so resounding  you will
see right away from the first quote that i brought you that he has a
great simplicity in his
argument about life but
above all it includes food and drink apartment
clothes and a few other things
you can actually say that this
thesis is hardly disputed if you read a few
months  don't eat anything drink then
you won't be there anymore and that
this simple statement is the
starting point of his philosophy he was
material is and he says the
basic material needs
are the basic material needs that
ultimately have to be the beginning of every
philosophy we mustn't start
from the spiritual  start out and what kind of
thoughts we have or of god or
religion or or of
reason like immanuel kant and think about
what we can't end up no the
human being is first and foremost a being with
basic needs and it has to
satisfy these needs in any case
and  that's why he then says such a
nice sentence that the first historical
act that people ever
did was probably that
they tried together to
provide food and drink for the
food i quote
the first historical act is therefore
the production of the means for
satisfaction of these needs
the production of material life
itself
and you have to imagine that was
perhaps the watch fetched that
went together for years that was the first
historical act
and with regard to this material
necessity that we always
have to have metabolism with nature
we appropriate nature  well we breathe
oxygen we we have to eat we
drink we are in mareks would say
it is a constant process of nature
appropriation and in this respect
we are nothing different and nothing better
than the animals but there is a very
specific fact that distinguishes the
human race from the  animals
differ how do we differ
from animals in terms of these
basic needs the animal also eats
and drinks human beings
that could be the difference
knife and fork knife and fork
of course we have cultural techniques
but marx would say the big
difference is the work the animals
don’t have to work  for
example
the the the the buffalo or the bison if
then a meadow and across the country the
graze they find their food
directly in nature they don't have to
work for it the human being has to
work for his food that's
a huge difference
for example if you  now you ca
n't just sit down and gas
it won't get it and if you
go to the supermarket and buy bread then
it means again that the bread
from the farmer who
plowed the field sowed who learned how to use the crane
was threshed then came  maybe a
wholesaler bought the grain then
mail was brought from it the flour
was packaged and brought to the bakeries
the bakers
made the bread there then it would be packaged again by
the third company and
finally it ended up in the supermarket
but there was nothing involved in the work processes
and  iks different professions and that's why
we differ from the animals
of course you could say now of course
the animals also sometimes work for
their food so the beaver for example
the constructions in the dam the work to
slow down the fish a bit so that it
can hunt more easily or the  ants
or bees also have a bit of
what we do division of labor that
threatens in our but says max that's
not nearly as universal as with
humans i quote they
themselves are starting
to differ from animals well people
people are starting to be different  distinguish them from animals
as soon as they start
producing their food
they produce their food and
now i come back to the ants
and bees marx also thought about it yes
the ants don’t work too they
build they build them in like that quote it
produces that too  animal it builds
a nest dwellings like the bee beaver ant
cetera alone it only produces
what it needs immediately for itself and its
young it produces one-sidedly
while humans produce universally
that is again a completely clear
statement we as humans produce
universally that means we
not only produce what he said here in the quote
what we ourselves
or our children need at the moment we manufacture let's
say shoes and not
only for us and our children but
these shoes will be sold to everyone who
needs shoes someone else makes
clothes here  not just for yourself
and your young one, but universally we
produce universally nowadays there are
over
14,000 different professions registered with the employment office so
people work so far their
philosophy is completely clear we have
needs we have to eat drink we
work and now comes the third
step  now it's getting more exciting now says
marx because he's material is said the
way we satisfy our material
needs by eating and drinking
the way we work
now plays a major role in what
we think what we feel for
our whole superstructure that's what it's called
the basis superstructure theory the basis is
always they are always the material
needs i'll quote
what people are
falls well what they the people are
falls together with their production
so will so both with what they
produce and with how they
produce i repeat  again, what
people are coincides with
their production, both with what they
produce and with how they
produce, so what we are, how we
feel, how we perceive ourselves, how
we, what we think, yes, our
self-confidence is fed by what
we work  we produce and how
we produce i'll give you a
simple example, another
buddhist monk who
has a vegetable garden in tibet and grows and harvests his soy there.
he's different and
feels different in his head than,
for example,
a master butcher or a yes
in a  big butcher shop or,
for example,
you as a student feel different from
someone who works at the post office, for example,
or everyone has their yes,
you laugh, you probably shop
at the post office, but fine,
but you already notice that it’s
how you work, how you
produce and what  you produce
plays a role in what kind of
consciousness you have that would
tell us and now comes the next
step he goes so far as to say
it's not just about what the
individual does, so whether he
's a boxer now  and
earns his living by boxing or whether he
is a singer and
earns his living by singing and no,
it's ultimately about what
society produces as a whole, how
the production contexts are as a whole,
how does
society reproduce itself, so
in what forms is in a
working together that's what's
exciting for karl marx and he says that
shapes us immensely i quote what the
individuals are it depends on
the material conditions of their
production it's not consciousness that
determines life but life that
determines consciousness
that's a very famous one  sentence by
karl marx a famous quote i
will repeat not
consciousness determines life but
life determines consciousness
you all probably know this quote
under the short under the short form
being determines consciousness
by that he means exactly that the way and
how  we work being like us
and eating and drinking how we get our
food determines what
we think and he goes one
step further the whole thing is interesting he
says religion family state i quote
right moral science art etc are
just special ways of producing
religion  family start right moral
science so everything the whole
superstructure everything that is in our heads
are just special ways of production
what does he mean by that why can
religion what does religion have to do with
how we work and what we
work how is religion a way
of production i will give you
an example back then where it becomes very very
clear that religion too
is only a certain way of the relics of production let’s take the
vikings let’s take the vikings as an example
the vikings what kind of
production do they have like  they produce
their livelihood
yes we know the vikings what do
the vikings live on what are the
famous and well known yes they were the
women who the vikings are a
loot follows they
attacked others you have to consider the
vikings lived in thule there is
not much  grown it was cold there
it was inhospitable so
at some point the vikings were dependent on
making additional raids got into
their dragon boats in
england and then attacked the european coasts
in general the villages sometimes
even went far inland on their
raids got the grain  the jewelery
yourself everything they got
even vessels everything they took loaded onto their
ships and went home again what kind of
religion did these people have what was their
supreme god it was of course
a god of war namely odin with the
sword in his hand  rather sitting
then they had an extra
god of war the door so it was a
warlike religion it wouldn't
have fit jesus christ of nazareth
also hold out your right hand that would
n't have fit for the vikings and there
you see exactly this thesis of base and
superstructure the base  of a people plundered by robbery
is the fight and it doesn't fit that
in the superstructure then charity comes
no there is a war god the agrarian
peoples in turn
live from agriculture the agrarian peoples
in turn usually have
harvest festivals and have a
peaceful god who worship  what
the sun or sacrifice to the god of thunder and
say yes we
hope that our harvest will not
be spoiled celebrate thanksgiving is
a completely different religion but the
mode of production the material mode of
production is reflected in religion, so to speak,
religion is
superstructure you can see it from that  the
sedentary farmers temple tree churches the
nomadic peoples like the israelis,
for example, carried the ark of the covenant
around with them, so the religion, the
rites, the traditions, the churches, everything,
the whole superstructure is the result of
how and on how what and how the peoples
have produced
now there is one more step
further he says this
this kind of production
is just crucial i quote
that again good because then we see
again the materialism it
understood itself as material is also
all engels communists were materialists
they wanted to start from the real needs
of the people and have them  set yourself
apart you have completely set yourself apart
from the idealists who
practiced contemporary philosophy at the time of
marx and engels and i
brought you a quote
quote in complete contrast to german
philosophy which descends from heaven to
earth by really
active people  starting out and from
their real life process also the
development of the ideological reflections
and echoes of this life process is
presented so you don't want to come
down from heavenly earth but you
start from the really active people
and from these active people you
look at which reflections and echoes are
in your head are the
material being determines the consciousness
and now the next step comes
again very stringently and clearly with karl
marx these echoes and reflexes that we
then have in our heads where we think
these are our own ideas
are
possibly not  only a smooth
reflection of our production
but they are ideology they are
sometimes
shaped by what is of interest to the ruling class
so the ruling
class determines how
and what is produced and in our
head it is often what the ruling
class thinks is right  stop i quote that
the dominant ideas of a time
were always only the ideas of the
ruling class the dominant
ideas of a time when always only the
ideas of the ruling class let
me give you an example for this too
take
feudalism there were kings
nobles and  there were the farmers and the
serfs and the farm workers the
lawless and the servants
the idea or how should I put it the
superstructure the ideology of this time
likes to focus on above all the
religion of course was the king
is king by god's grace and the
nobleman has blue  blood and the nobles
as a whole were chosen by god
through their birth to rule
and the servant is a servant by god's
grace also the servant god placed in a
certain place in society
to
test him life was defined
as a great test and at the  in the end
the farmhand or the complete peasant
or the serf was also rewarded with
eternal life if instead of
serving instead of serving god has
worked well and lived honestly and uprightly
and then max says exactly that is
ideology that is the ruling that
is how should i say these are the
ideas of the ruling class this is
not necessarily good for everyone this
medieval way of thinking that
people had back then
and that is why he criticized religion
massively religion is for him and
we put that very nicely here in this quote
the sigh of the oppressed
creature is also a quote, of course, it
is the opium of the people, also a very
famous quote from karl marx, religion
is the opium of the people, what he
wants to say is that religion in particular often
comforts people
to a paradise beyond  after
earthly life and the ideological, the
false awareness of this
religiosity consists in the fact
that we then no longer direct our energy
to this world and instead of
the oppressed in this world
ensuring that they
create justice and
become happier, they direct all their strength to
the afterlife  and as a result, the power
from the beyond to thinking is withdrawn from this world
to the beyond and then
we can't change the sites
and that's why marx criticizes religion
massively and was a sharp opponent of
every form of religion right quote
the abolition of religion as
illusory happiness  of the people is the
promotion of their real happiness so
at the moment when we can abolish the illusion of
religion we ask yes
what can we do here what
can we do in reality to
make life worth living for everyone
well
now
we come
to one  core thoughts of marx on
a very central element of his
philosophy on the so-called his thomas
on historical materialism and
i have brought you a
wonderful graphic here you can see
the development of all
human societies since the
beginning, so to speak, the first
civilization right at the beginning down here
we have  the whole society
what does target society mean who knows who knows
who as a latina will
learn latin dance dance dance yes the
gender yes the tribe the gender is
correct both genders merovingian
garling the tribe
marx and engels mean by that the
tribal society at the beginning we had a
tribal society the people are  in
the uaw tube who in tribes mostly
moved around with each other with a large degree of kinship
and be it normalized but also the
first sedentary ones have a
tribal society and that is
now decisive and here we can see
it again perhaps in the
graphic I have in that  depicted that
was still a classless society
this genthin society
did not yet know property of course
they did not know property here there is
also a nice example the
north american indians who, for
example as a tribe as a game
target society, followed the bison
when the bison herds
grazed a huge area
then the bison moved on then
the indians when the distance to
this herd got too big that their
hunters
had to prepare for days and weeks forever until they were with the bison
back what did the
indians do they
broke down their teams their tents  and
followed the bison
and when such an indian tribe
moved on you see that
property was completely superfluous for the
indians because
the accounts only take them with them they put the
tent poles on the right and left of the
horse two poles
stretched falls between them or
these  today, with the ones you made the field with, with
which you made the tent waterproof,
you put everything in
and then you moved on. more
property was not possible
divided even when the indians
went hunting and then
separated some buffalo from the herd and
were able to kill them with his bow they brought
the bison
back and divided it up among everyone
here too yes communism i
find that very interesting that marx
and engels discovered the classless society at the beginning of history
and
their thesis is certainly not wrong,
survival was so hard back then that
generally everyone pulled together,
even in the germanic
societies, if one is to believe the
descriptions of the historian tacitus,
the germans did
lived communist
tacitus describes that half of the
germanic peoples always built
and tended the fields and the other half
went to war and the next
year it was the other way round, they had to stay at home
and cultivate the fields and the
other half went to war
and also tried to make booty
but you can see that everything was shared here too
that was also one
huge field on which they worked
and of course the harvest was
shared that was the first
social self-organization the
society then came the society
’s slave owners and this is what
happened  unfortunately, something decisive
here, property is introduced and at
the moment when there was property, there were
huge estates, there were those who
were rich, who had something and who had
nothing, the real
farm workers, or they were
slaves or just farmers without rights and
since that time  be it property there
are always constant
conflicts between
slaves and landowners then between
nobles and
rebellious peasants bourgeois or here
between in capitalist
society between capitalists and
work then there are constant
conflicts yes the only
reasonably peaceful society was
society as a whole but  since
the time what property is about we have had
a constant argument in
history it was once quoted
the history of all previous
society is the history of
class struggles
free and slave patrician and liebherr
baron and serf to citizen and social
briefly oppressor and
oppressed stood in constant
opposition to each other  a struggle
that ended every time with a revolutionary
reorganization of the whole society
so the history of all
previous society is a
history of class struggles also a
central sentence of max history is
history of class struggles
and just between the free and the
slave patricia tim he stayed with us  there were
always bad, angry
arguments just think
about it you all know spartacus the
slaves standing up or i would like to
give you another example i would like to show you how, so
to speak, the dialectics of the
class struggles drove history forward
dialectics insofar as karl marx says
every ruling social
class creates its own opponents and
he calls that negation
and these opponents become stronger
and stronger and then replace the respective ruling
class but the interesting thing is that
they produce their own opponents i'll
show you that i'll go
back briefly here  I'll show you that with
this graphic at the transition from
feudal society to
capitalist society
I'll show you the dialectics in
feudal society,
as I've already indicated before, we had
the nobles who didn't
work, the peasants,
so to speak, produced and away  the
nobles loved and the interesting thing is
now but that's for the nobles
around it was to
work the women back then
wore parasols not like they do
today that he lay in the sun
and get a tan no then it was
a  sign of high birth and of
dignity if you were snow white so you
wore the parasols so as
not to get too much color in your face
that you think you are a
peasant girl they protected themselves from the
sun the nobility also did not
trade that was also  completely
frowned upon that a nobleman who trades
or also manufactures a
craft that was not a matter for the
side the good point was now but
that precisely because the nobleman
avoided these things, so to speak, or who did
not consider them to be befitting of their status
are the citizens  the craftsmen
have become more and more powerful the craftsmen were the
first manufactory owners and the
dealers you have to remember there were
always larger trading offices ag the
fokkers then up north the trades
he is ever larger trading offices and
the dealers have become richer and richer
and all of a sudden the nobles had  even
debts to the traders now the
manufacturers also made more on a fraction
of the land that the nobles
had available the concerns
had huge estates but the farmers
then only ever brought this harvest
while in the manufactories in
the first factories there was
much more  produces and generates a lot
more capital the land factor
was no longer so important and
suddenly the bourgeoisie
became more and more powerful and then more and
more nobles were indebted to the bourgeoisie
and at some point the bourgeoisie said
yes, actually we are the driving
force of our society yes  we
create the capital we act we
do and the aristocrats have the
right to rule politically and that is
no longer possible and suddenly there were
bourgeois revolutions and
at this point we see here between the
feudal society and the
capitalist or you could also say
city capitalist society
we say bourgeois
society there was a bourgeois
revolution in england,
as you may also know, the king was beheaded
and the lower house
took over power in france
the king, royal couple or even the
woman were also beheaded and there was bloody
revolution until the bourgeoisie or what
may they be a bit yes a bit
critical calls the bourgeoisie said the
bourgeoisie then
took over power but you can see one thing
i just wanted to explain to you
what is dialectics feudalism itself
has produced its own negation
by, so to speak, this this
both the  trade production
manufacturing did
not see everything as befitting their status
first made the bourgeoisie strong its
own negation and now it is getting even more
exciting
interesting way is happening
again what the bourgeoisie has
now released an insane
productivity i think
i brought you a quote yes  here
we look at after the
bourgeoisie was in power the
bourgeoisie
sachs pulls the castle what it has created in
its barely 100 years of
class rule
massive honor and colossal
reproductive forces than all
past generations together it is
not nice the bourgeoisie has
massive and  colossal reproductive
forces created by all past
generations together and that is
of course understandable and is
actually the case you have to imagine back
then it was
17 89 in France with the bourgeois revolutions
then the industrial revolution started then
they say 17 18 is the
take-off  for the industrial revolution
from 17 80 to
1818 68 10 10 for decency steamships
across the ocean and then until 18.50
huge railway lines will be built the
coal mines will be closed
steel will be cast there are
textile factories everywhere the huge the
industrial revolution will get one
insane dynamics and the bourgeoisie
was self-confident wilkinson, for example,
still produces these razor blades
actually now don't name any brands of
the hand i want to give you the example
to show you the
euphoria in the bourgeoisie when the
staff had crowns and heavy ones under a cap
i think
steel pillars over ten meters high in a steel
says let bury so great was the
enthusiasm at the time and the bourgeoisie
actually produced the bourgeoisie insanely during the
industrial revolution
produced more than any
target society before that also more than
the slave-owning society also more
than them  fund company and yet
this enormously successful
bourgeoisie, which distinguishes a large
petty bourgeoisie, has also
produced its own negation
worked more in the countryside on the farms but in the factories
a new social group
emerged, namely the workers or whatever
the proletariat says
politicians because the bourgeoisie
paid these workers miserably, of course, there were also catastrophic conditions at the time
there were
hardly any sewage systems in the workers' settlements
there
were cases of cholera typhus it was
hard to imagine in the
mines the mines often
collapsed there were wise is
catastrophic conditions the women
had to work the same way the children
and the working hours hold tight
was twelve to 14 hours
and nevertheless due to the
population explosion during this time the
production was not increased
in the factories and more and more
workers have
witnessed this misery so to speak and here says
it may be something very nice he says because of that it
is now the  negation of the
bourgeoisie arose i quote
capitalist production creates its own negation with
the necessity of a natural process
it is the negation of
the negation
isn’t that wonderful
capitalist production creates with
the necessity of a natural process
there we have it again that he says there are
laws of motion  in history
and with the necessity of a natural
process,
capitalism produces its own negation, so to speak, and
that is the negation of the negation,
we know why it is the negation of the
negation, because the bourgeoisie, the
bourgeoisie that came to power,
was the negation of the nobility  and the
workforce the workers are now
the negation of the bourgeoisie ergo the
negation of the negation if you
relate it back to the nobility then
the story keeps moving forward and
now
and again a very clear and
brilliant thought from karl marx he
might say something to them  it's still important we'll
mention that i've
now forgotten it's
absolutely necessary at this point because of this
catastrophic situation of the workers,
marx and engels now saw the time had
come for the
workforce to actually
take over and have political power in the european countries  international
to revolutions in europe yes you could
say called worldwide to initiate a new
historical epoch namely
the classless society and i
have brought you this very famous
sentence from the communist manifesto
that has been published thousands of times
and it is quoted as saying the political arians
have nothing to do with it  lose than your
chains you have a world to win
proletarians of all countries unite
also very nice proletarians of all countries
unite this
international call for marx it was
of course a catastrophe that often in
wars then the workers in
germany had to close against workers in france
instead  that they have aimed their weapons
against the bourgeoisie
and mag founded the international
to prevent ever again
german french english work
shooting at each other there they should
no longer allow themselves to be abused by the
bourgeoisie but rather
take power themselves
is crucial but and see  you
again the clarity of max he is
material is now he says the
revolution he said before
will not come because he or engels call
for revolution in the communist manifesto
that would be idealism again
someone thinks up something and says okay
we have to do that now  implement no the
revolution comes for another reason
it comes because of the developed
material production conditions
here too he remains true to materialism he
says communism comes because of this or
the revolution because capitalism
abolishes itself due to its material mode of production he gets into
internal contradictions capitalism
suddenly gets into inner contradictions
these contradictions are getting bigger
and in the end capitalism collapses
that is also interesting for us today
and we have to
take a closer look at it
and this theory that capitalism ultimately
fails because of its own imperatives i would like to briefly tell you now
portray marx did this in
his very famous book capital
and i am now making the
ambitious attempt to convey the three central theories from capital to you in
just 3 4 sentences, on
the one hand
the
surplus value theory, on the other hand the
accumulation to the concentration theory
and third, the impoverishment theory
if you understand the three building blocks you
already understand the cornerstones
of capital i will start with
the surplus value theory
the worker gives accumulated
labor more value than it had
before
the worker gives accumulated
labor more value  value than you
had before i think
the best way to show you the theory of added value is to give you
an example back then
textile factories were springing up all over the place
there was this sentence by the famous
english historian arnold toynbee when you
say cotton you mean manchester
in manchester there is a cotton and
textile factory  one after the other were
brought up and for the first time
everyone in england had something
to wear so you have to say
that the industrial revolution has of
course also brought a lot
and now let's take a worker
from a textile factory who produces let's
say what do I know  50 100 hands
a day
and then he starts work so it comes let's
say there are spinning machines
there is a loom hundreds of looms
hundreds of spinning machines and one work
then he's standing now no matter whether he's spinning
on the spinning genius or another the
machine and guides the way through the
shuttle  in total if you
counted down his work
he would produce 50 ducks that
doesn’t make it very highly specialized on its own, of course,
but he would total
this proportion of hands you can count on him
as production for this the
entrepreneur wins 1000 euros
if he sells them in the shop
but the worker only paid 100 euros now
the added value would logically be 900
euros now says but of
course you can of course you have to consider the entrepreneur
still pays rent for his factory he has to
pay for his machines he also has to
branch off a bit for his family and himself so there are a few more to come  but
even if you subtract all of them,
marx says there are
still 600 or 500 euros left over and that is
the real added value, so the
capitalist does not really give
what his work is worth at work, but he
gives him less and the added value
container himself
and as a result, of course, he created an insane
amount of capital because he not
only has the added value that one worker
produces he had maybe a hundred
maybe 500 workers and this
accumulates a huge amount of capital
quote a worker in a cotton
factory he only produces cotton materials
no he produces capital
and that is now the basic law of
all capitalism that the
capitalist must of course produce added value
if you only
make -0 then that is not enough and that is why
marx says quote
production of added value or plus
macherey are the absolute law of this mode of
production why is that
absolute law why can't anyone
go out and say where i give the
workers twice as much or i
pour out all my profits i don't create
any added value it wouldn't work
because the capitalist
needs added value and takes it and can
of course be reinvested he buys himself  already
first yacht and bought a few
houses in davos but at some point
reinvested a large amount of capital
back into the company in production
and why does he have to do that he has to
reinvest because otherwise he
will be swallowed up by others because and now i come
to the next point about accumulation  and
concentration theory
you have to think about it
by reinvesting the capital that
gains from the added value
can hire even more workers can
produce even more he can
conquer new markets he can say so far
i have only supplied england with shirts
now i also supply germany and
france with hands  etc. but
at some point he conquered the whole market
what does he do when he realizes
he just can't
sell hands anymore then it doesn't make sense
to hire more workers and
expand production no then
see how can I make even more profit
and then see  aha there is
another one who produces shirts
and then tried to destroy his business
or buy it or
take it over and how does he do it how does
the competitive struggle work in
capitalism or i can also say in
the free market economy we say  yes
today free market economy how is
the competition going it is about
making the goods cheaper the goods are made cheaply as may say they are
made cheaply and the trick is quite
simple if you succeed
as an entrepreneur simply sell your shirts for a
whole year just for the  if the
competitor sells half the price
then the competitor has
difficulties because the competitor can
no longer sell a single shirt
if, of course, everyone buys their shirts
if they are only half the price and
you have to persevere with that
and you can persevere if you  if you
have a lot of capital then you can
afford to do it, it doesn’t matter,
but after one year the other person is
bankrupt, then you buy his company
or he disappears from the market and
then you get the money back
in quickly because then of course you are the only ones to run
this huge  able to serve the market
and max saw that i'll quote
the fineness the cheapness of the
goods depends on the productivity of the
work but this depends on the scale
of production the larger capital
therefore beat the smaller ones
a nice set of big capital beat
small capital  larger capital
beat the smaller ones clearly because
those who have more resources who
have more capital can afford to
hold out longer in the price war at the cheap price someone who
has no capital reserves can go with them at the beginning
if they see the competition
makes it so cheap i have to be
under the  price but after half a
year it can't be done anymore if the
debts are too big the bank wo
n't give you any more credit he's
broke that's why big capitals hit small
capitals now the following is happening
now it's getting more and more exciting quote
one capitalist kills many dead hand
hand in hand with this centralization and
exploration of many capitalists by
a few, the conscious development of the
technical application of science, the
planned exploitation of the earth, the
slurring of all peoples into the network
of the world market and thus the
international character of the
capitalist system, one
capitalist at a time kills many dead hand in hand
hand with this centralization and
exploration that means exploration is
latin that means expropriation with the
expropriation of many capitalists by
a few clearly the richer capitalists
who merge who buy other
companies who try
to get bigger and hand in hand with that
something second happens and that find  i
particularly great karl max kelly
in the mid-nineteenth century well
but the communist manifesto was 18 48
well if we consider that he
was already here globalization for you it was
all just beginning at that time
there were still national economies
and he says here already
those  conscious technical application of
science the planned exploitation
of the earth the slurring of all peoples
into the network of the world market that is exactly
the globalization that he said
and in this context the
following is happening now
through the concentration and accumulation
of capital,
interestingly enough, there is
always an  greater wealth for the
few capitalists there will
always be more billionaires more and more
millionaires but on the other hand
max says the workers and the
population will become poorer and poorer there
will be more and more low earners
and more and more rich
karl marx predicts through the
concentration process and  now comes
as an interesting quote he says the
capital can grow enormously in
one hand because it is withdrawn there in
many individual hands
isn't that wonderful the capital
can grow enormously in one
hand because it is there in many
individual hands  is withdrawn and
the exciting thing is to say that yes, it
is not the capitalist who is to blame in a
moral sense, but the big bourgeois
who now has a company or a
factory and shareholders who can
not help but try again and again
to
rationalize who is like Marx  under
enormous
pressure to rationalize he has to
try, so to speak, to keep his competitors at bay
if he doesn't
do that if he doesn't
try to replace the workers with machines
cheaper to become inexpensive then
at some point he will disappear from the market to the
market the products are too expensive will
no longer be  bought then it makes you
bankrupt or is swallowed up by someone
else that’s why in the economy
like marx only the rule applies you have to grow
otherwise you’ll be eaten yourself and
that now means that a
capitalist kills many people and there is
more and more capital accumulation and
the  impoverishment, which is now also interesting,
comes at a certain point in
production because production
becomes self-contradictory there
i will first show you the quote
about the constantly decreasing number of
capital magnates it is clear to us yes
of course they are decreasing the capital magnates
because it  there are ever larger mergers and
global corporations with the constantly
decreasing number of capital magnates
the mass of misery the pressure
of servitude the degeneration of
exploitation is growing but also the indignation of the
constantly swelling working class
why is the misery increasing now when we
have an ever smaller number of capitalists the  the reason is quite
simple mag says at some point production will be so
efficient and in his time
it was already the case that
more and
more workers were laid off due to the pressure to rationalize and were
replaced by machines there was
a weaver uprising back then you have to introduce
yourself to the weavers  they
always had these weavers' shuttles,
these threads were stretched and they pulled
these shuttles through again,
tightened them with a rake and that's how these
lengths of fabric came about and suddenly
a machine made it and then
this machine could even have been
operated by steam  these
steam engines produced 1000 times as much
as we ten workers and
then of course the
capitalists bought more and more machines,
machines are spinning machines
and the workers laid off and
produced an insane amount of fabrics pants shirts with fewer and fewer workers
what was but the problem eventually
had  the workers had no
more money when they were unemployed we
have to think we had to think back then there was no
unemployment insurance in the sense
that there were political masses that
arose, they
fell down from hunger on the streets is
catastrophic the church
still fed the poor in some cases  but
more and more politicians
came into existence, namely penniless proletarians, and as a result, it can be
said that the
ever-growing working class was outraged, because
now a crazy spiral was set in
motion, the factories
produced more and more perfectly, but
they could no longer buy the work then
the capitalists what did they do they
shut down production
noticed funny the shirts do
n't work anymore we don't need that
many anymore the warehouses are full we
produce less we did short-time work
at some point they didn't do anything
anymore dismissed all the workers
because they didn't buy anything anymore anyway
was and the more workers were laid off,
the less was the purchasing power there
is it was a spiral that
has switched down and down and in the end
like marx thousands 100,000 of the
workers in europe will be standing in front of the factory gates
in the factory are
highly developed good machines the warehouses
are full but no one can buy it anymore
and that is the inner
contradiction of capitalism if they
capitalism abolishes
itself through its inner
contradictions the means of production
themselves come into contradiction with each other
perfect machines great factories
but thousands of unemployed are just outside the gates
and nobody comes anymore  come on the
machines stand still capitalism is
paralyzed let's have a look at
this quote at a certain stage of
their development the
material productive forces of
society come into contradiction with the
existing production conditions
that's what i tried to
explain to you it's not because marx  and
capture engels idealistically we need
a revolution because the chapter
production itself gives up
i quote again the centralization
of the means of production and the
socialization of labor reach
a point where they become incompatible
with their capitalist shell it
is blown up the exporters are
also expressed again  a wonderful
sentence by max the
exporters are expressed in german
the expropriation so those who
have expropriated others are now
expropriated themselves the capitalists have
namely expropriated andré they have
first tried to buy up other entrepreneurs
in the price war by making the goods cheaper to
finish them off until they then do that
companies were able to buy up or
take over and have thus
expropriated more and more others and
created a market power and now
they and their own
are being expropriated the expo operators are wrong ex-professionals
and now something very
decisive happens the workers take over
the factories in a quite
violent act  this is a
revolution in the political revolution the
workers not only take over the
economic power but also the political power
it forms the workers' councils and it
is also called marx that give the dictatorship
of the proletariat this dictatorship
of the proletariat is, however, according to
karl marx a transitional state that is to
say
the dictatorship  of the proletariat is only
needed until all
companies are actually converted into nationally owned companies
and until the
class contradiction is abolished, so to speak, because
something wonderful is happening now because things are
now being produced collectively
because the factories belong to everyone,
not just to the workers who
work there but to the whole  people
suddenly there is
no longer the contrast between the bourgeoisie and
the workers because even the burghers
have to work in the factory or
help out certain functions they
can no longer opt out
and as a result
the classes are completely independent of
me  quote what that looks like no
i wanted to show you something else
that seems important to me namely
[music]
hamas here we look at this graphic again
interestingly enough with marx you remember
it starts with the classless
society of society think
of him  North African Indian tribes
then come all the class
societies, the slave owners, the
fatal society, the capitalist
society and the communist
society,
and here at the end, through the
communist society, we come
back to the classless state that
at the beginning of history manufacturers
classless society
class society classless, i.e.
makes history  almost a ghost if
you will, however, on a much,
much higher
level of production, on a much higher
level of production, we are
returning to the classless society,
unfortunately, marx has not
explained exactly, and neither has engels exactly how
the communist
society should then be implemented,
he speaks  of free associations
of all citizens and of all people in
this state and of a
planned economy led by a
planned economy led
production
and
this planned economy led the
production that we know nowadays
which of course also has its problems
is yes then 100 years after marx has
numerous or even earlier  the numbers
used october revolution in
russia it was much earlier in
1919 so you have to see that there were
attempts to produce in a planned economy in the sense of
karl marx
and there were state-owned
companies but they also had a
problem and they had it  the problem is
that they sometimes produced too much
of a product, sometimes too little, then
production was changed and you have to
remember that it is difficult to always be able to react quickly to the
rapidly changing needs of the
population,
and overall
that was of course also considered  Deficiencies in the economy
are then interpreted by the people and
in the end you know the result,
the citizens in the socialist-
communist societies themselves have
turned their backs on communism, but
nevertheless one has to say that max, of
course, gave us a wonderful set of instruments with his critical analysis
of capitalism
does
the free
market economy really have to tap into it nowadays
and see where are
the crises where are these
these problems good finally
i would like to ask the question finally
i would like to ask the question
what else does karl marx have to say to us
today what  use and use this
body of thought today and one thing can be
said,
let's take the accumulation
theory, the accumulation
and concentration theory,
this thesis from the capital is of
downright frightening topicality
if you think about it,
not a month goes by
that you can't see it in the news
how
another corporation has bought up another company how there are
huge supranational mergers again,
of course we have cartels that
are trying to prevent exactly that because
the whole free
market economy, capitalism thrives
on the fact that different entrepreneurs
offer the same products and
undercut each other, but also  the
antitrust authorities can't do it if we
look at the large number of companies and that can be statistically proven then there is still the
concentration process criticized by marx small example just a
few decades ago we had
a large
number of
energy companies
today
you can  count the big energy companies
the energy suppliers on one
hand or go to the
supermarket and you will find a lot of colorfully
packaged different products but
ultimately about 30 percent of these
products come from a single large
food company so the
concentration is undoubtedly still
a huge problem, even if
of course we try to
put a stop to it politically
secondly and i
brought him another quote secondly secondly the
impoverishment theory may say that through
the free market economy through
capitalism at some point in the context of
concentration the rich
will get richer and the poor will get poorer and
actually  unfortunately we have to say that
although we founded a social market economy after the war
and
there was an attempt from the political side
to create capitalism with a human face,
unemployment benefit was introduced
social insurance social assistance health
insurance pension insurance
so that people even if they
get sick if they are old or  being unemployed was
carried by capitalism and
was not immediately miserable as was the case at the time
of marx so one
tried to narrow
the gap between rich and poor
a bit with the social market economy, but
you all know that in the european
states there is not a single state  in
which poor and rich are converging we
are actually faced with the fact that
in the federal republic of germany
we have more and more higher earners more and
more millionaires more and more
billionaires and actually an ever
larger, rapidly growing number of
low earners so this gap between
rich and poor is widening and
it doesn't matter at all whether
our government
is social democratic or conservative
the gap between rich and poor has
widened in each government period
and that is of course
worrying there are also the big
differences between north and south, i.e.
between developing countries and
industrialized countries  but even in
the industrialized countries
we don't manage to
redistribute capital in any way in such a way that the gap
between rich and poor no longer exists
and marx expressed a third questionable
criticism of the system which i want to
mention at the end
he wanted the quote by the way  i'll
tell you more because i think it's just
brilliant let's take a
quick look again the capital can
grow enormously in one hand because it is withdrawn from there by many individual
hands that's exactly the
gap between rich and poor good and
the third  point where max
has set a thorn even today that is
true i have brought you
another quote here he says that modern
bourgeois society has conjured up such
enormous means of production and transport
like the
sorcerer who is
no longer able to control the subterranean forces who
conjured up repeat
once again modern bourgeois
society, which
has conjured up such a tremendous production of means of transport,
like the sorcerer who
is no longer able to control the forces, who
conjured up and in fact I
mean you can
hardly describe the current situation better than what
karl marx did before, let me calculate,
about
150  years yes a good 150 years
because today it is the same
just think of the banking crisis yes that
came like a bad magic on everyone the
politicians pointed to the bankers
the bankers pointed to the real estate funds
that the interest was not paid
said the customers want
high returns so we have to
invest speculatively in order to satisfy the high returns the
customers want and so on
everyone has to go out on the other
ultimately it was their and how should I
put it the self-interest and also the
bonuses of the bankers that has  everything
played together the plus macherey
we saw the plus macherey earlier in the quote
that is the basic law of the free
market economy then leads to the fact that,
like a sorcerer, the forces
that are released are no longer
controlled it flows like there are
huge global capital and
financial flows where  the national
governments are of course completely overwhelmed,
as we can
see from the debt crisis, for example, so here too
max said something to us, the question
now is what is the alternative if we
say marx is right with his criticism,
the planned economy we have already
seen is unfortunately  it didn't
really work the way
it could have worked the free,
completely neoliberal or liberal
market economy
doesn't work either, we see that
too, so maybe the solution lies
somewhere in the middle, that we have to try to
control the market economy and
set limits, but that  is now
speculation and one would also have to
consider how one
can realize it at all a middle way
between a planned economy and free
capitalism before I speculate
I want to tell you a
wonderful concrete vision of karl marx at the end
he
actually has what I think is a brilliant
prediction  made that the
productivity can always be higher
and can be increased yes he says
here the real wealth of the
society does not depend on the
length of the overtime but on its
productivity so the real
wealth of the society does not depend
on the length of the overtime but on
it  productivity
that means
in the sense of max it is not so important
that we work eight hours a day for a long time
or that we
raise the retirement age to 70 years,
but productivity has to increase
and the prosperity of society depends on it
and in fact
productivity is  of course it has grown a lot
in the last decades
and one has to say nowadays we can
afford it or what do we mean we can
afford it we afford it in all
modern european societies
that we release millions of people from
work we have millions of
unemployed in every european
state and the  are no longer
involved in production and that
of course speaks for the high
productivity that we have with our
machines
and the point is now that karl
marx says it's actually a good
thing that we produce so well and
that was his vision that at some point we would
parts of the population
can free themselves from
the necessity of work for science, art and culture and then
we can enter the realm of freedom
and i think it’s brilliant that
karl marx will always do the work for you
that material is the basis for everything that
he is like that  a vision developed
that at the end of history
productivity might be so high that
individuals no longer have to work so long,
so the reduction in working hours was
the massive promotion of marx that we
might only work 20 hours a day
and the remaining time,
so to speak, for self-development as
have ends in themselves i quote the
time the realm of freedom does in fact only begin where the work that is
determined by necessity and external expediency
stops beyond that begins the
development of human strength which is
considered an end in itself the true realm of
freedom i.e. the realm of freedom
we will achieve when the work that
is determined by necessity stops and max
would be today is certainly a
representative of the unconditional
basic income
because that also shows that these
people who we can no longer get into the
work process 1 the unemployed
must of course also
have the opportunity, so to speak  to be able to
devote art to culture to science, which
is hardly the case today due to the
low
opportunities that you
have financially and pecuniarily, yes, that might
still be a vision that I
think
should also be realizable for us today, at least
we should pursue this goal and
last  i would like to leave the last word to
the philosopher karl marx he did
something wonderful when he was 17 years old do
n't pinpoint me it could have been 16 18 years old
but it was at least
in one of his high school diplomas he
said something really wonderful what  once
again reflects the spirit
of karl marx and
he said quote man is a species
sweden
that means on the one hand that we are not,
as we are always suggested,
perhaps also ideologically suggested
in capitalism we are not
just
egoists who pay attention to our own interests
and  get the
best out of yourself and practice self-optimization
no said human beings are by
nature a sweden species that
means we live in community we
live in families in societies we
go to the football stadium together
we are a sociable being and secondly
does this sentence also
say that our destiny, so to speak, is to be
satisfied and to realize ourselves in the
community and here
comes his final quote he says
human nature is set up in such a way
that he
can only achieve perfection if he works for the good of
his fellow world  said if he only
creates for himself he may well be a
famous scholar a great white
man an excellent poet but not
a consummate truly great human being
so who can only create for himself
it was a famous
poet become a great scientist
but he will never become one  to be a consummate,
truly great human being because for this
he must also become for the good of his contemporaries
in this sense i can
only wish you or us that we
succeed in
recognizing us as a species
and, so to speak, in finding our destiny in such a
way that we not
only on  looking at our own interests
but always keeping an eye on the big picture
and in the sense of
karl marx that of course means our environment
ultimately yes humanity thank you very much
[applause]